can't go by danger he could go by shaft
he'd go by shafty he could go by
d shaft that's god's gummy yes it does
has the god's comment
excuse me sean yeah can i talk to my
baby's daddy of course thank you
how are you feeling my little chocolate
chippy chip oh i'm i'm fine you
you know i didn't really faint before i
was just resting my legs yes
rest those legs now listen i know all of
this happened very fast
yes so burton
guster will
you oh time out uh ceremony i think
you've flip-flopped the
situation here sean you're ruining
everything
this is exactly how i imagined it would
go
i'm gonna be a god mother chief she's my
best friend
so burt and guster will you make me the
happiest woman on this planet
on eris and pluto and pluto
and marry me yes i will do that
now sailor name will you marry
me and protect me from spiders and polar
bears and
to live next door to sean and jewels and
have connecting pools in our backyards
and a lazy river running through our
living rooms oh that's a
ton to unpack it is um you know what
yes i will yes
[Music]
i'm sure you're not upset about the
whole no kid thing
what oh not even a little oh i love you
oh yeah you're my person
yeah now
we just have one tiny little detail to
iron out what's that
i'm still married what don't worry about
it we'll figure it out
[Music]
me
you